bien l'armement donner la parole aux un
moment pour claudel que vous avez
rencontrées aussi en valois pourquoi
mais marie josèphe guerre vous avez donc
consacré sorte de première biographie et
claudel à travers à travers ses travers
son oeuvre oui parce que j'estime qu'un
créateur on le définit trop souvent à
travers des événements des anecdotes des
dates
aujourd'hui la manger telle chose qu'on
appelle les comptes de blanchisserie est
pour moi un créateur c'est d'abord dans
son oeuvre qu'on le trouve et pas
seulement dans ses aveux mais beaucoup
plus dans ce qu'ils cachent dans les
petites tricheries dans les
métamorphoses et l'oeuvre de claudel est
bourré de ce genre de choses claudel
avait une horreur absolue de tout ce qui
était autobiographie sans doute parce
qu'il avait peur qu'on le découvre enfin
en tout cas il y avait certainement cela
et il a passé en fait toute sa vie et
toute son oeuvre a essayé de se
reconstruire de se dissimuler de tricher
avec l'essai de tricher avec les
événements de ceux de se refaire en
quelque sorte de ce retrait donc c'était
passionnant de partir de 7h de
s'apercevoir par exemple quand on lit le
journal
il a tenu un journal intime pendant 50
ans de sa vie ce qui est énorme gardé
par des vigiles et de volumes dans la
pléiade et bien dans ce journal il ya
six mois de tous absolu rien pas une
référence par une date pas une allusion
pas un nom et on s'appelle reviens
entendu c'est surprenant
pourquoi ces six mois quoi ça correspond
et on s'aperçoit que c'est justement
pendant cette période qu'il a vécu la
crise la plus la plus extraordinaire de
son existence ça a été l'époque de sa
grande passion pour ce match ça a été
une époque où il était tellement
tellement amoureux tellement meurtri
tellement des faits qu'il a abandonné
les sacrements qu'il a été prêt à trahir
ses amis il était ami philippe berthelot
qui l'a à risquer de perdre même de
ruiner sa carrière qu'il a récité le
blâme et n'en dit rien on ne trouve que
quelques années après enfin un an puis
des quelques petites allusions qui vous
permettent de reconstruire
ne serait-ce qu'une découverte comme
celle là ça donne envie d'aller plus
loin il essayer de sonder pourquoi ces
silences pourquoi au contraire ses aveux
à quoi ça correspond le il ya trois
rencontres importantes dans la vie
quotidienne c'est rimbaud dieu et madame
rose beach voilà celui en question à
long terme et verdon est également
important jean yves berteloot cible
berthelot
oui bien sûr mon père oui mais enfin la
7e déterminant rimbaud c'est la poésie
man et de lui le lion rabot et nous lui
devons le premier c'est lui qu'il faut
mais l'addition la qualité sur les vieux
c'est que pendant que les deux hommes
sont différents quand je dis dieu non
c'est vrai je suis pas tout à retraite
20 non non non non je trouve que sur
claudel on a des préjugés
on croit que claudel c'est le bourgeois
installé c'est le croyant sans faille
c'est l'homme qui a une vie extrêmement
régulière pas du tout claudel c'était
aussi un anarchiste comme rimbaud c'est
aussi quelqu'un qui a fui c'est aussi
quelqu'un qui a été capable de passion
folle à tel point que dans partage le
midi quand il raconte sa passion
amoureuse il écrit alors qu'il est
croyant et qu'il prétend que sa croyance
est la première chose est il écrit au
dessus de l'amour il n'y a rien et pas
vous même dieu c'est spectaculaire comme
aveu et ce qui est encore plus
spectaculaire c'est que 50 ans après
quand il a repris partage de midi il a
supprimé cet aveu c'est quand même assez
bouleversant c'est une trahison par
rapport à sa vie ça prouve bien que
c'était quelqu'un qui était capable
aussi de deux ou les choses avec cécile
paris quand même tout à fait d'accord
c'est quand même un grand patriarche un
paysan installés soit avec sofa lycée
mélangeant les époques de cabourg oui
d'accord mais j'avais un beau d'avoir
terminé comme ça je suis très surpris de
ce que dit mais l'ambiance parce que
j'aimais le groupe chez personnellement
de n'avoir pas mis l'accent sur serein
beau un peu paillard un peu rigole à
plein de choses dans son journal
jal en asie j'ai parlé de son humour
j'ai parlé de son plus gros salon du
bourget parler de sa gourmandise
oui j'ai parlé tout excès j'ai parlé de
ces fuites c'est ben laden comme un
homme le sens grande sensualité de
gourmands oui l'histoire il a découvert
de la venue à trente et un autre à deux
ans le vieil découvre l'amour comme
beaucoup d in innovation pas découvre la
passion alors fini on ne tient pas
forcément qu'une chronique d'une passion
c'est pour ça que ce silence c'est que
de cela il ne parle pas de feu la cour
de cette passion mais sinon pas si l'on
parle pas dans l'immédiat il m'a parle
que d'elle dans toute son oeuvre et dans
sa correspondance et notre raison d'un
vent si jamais il y en a mais en parle
pas il n'y a pas de chronique
il n'y a pas de kooning
un an après il raconte quand même la
poursuite qu'il a fait de rosette à
travers la hollande
oui où il rencontrait chaque fois des
portes closes et qu'il faut dire aux
téléspectateurs madame roosevelt et
marié elle a quatre enfants elle a
quatre enfants et est une passion
dévorante pour elle oui et il ya
probablement la fille de pandas vivent
encore bien sûr elle est toujours
vivante
vous la connaissez oui j'ai rencontré
béatrice fait oui je vais parler
interviewé c'est beaucoup dire parce
qu'elles cachent elles se cachent elles
refusaient la peur et c'est quelqu'un
qui serait marquée si elle a connu bien
sûr elle l'a connu il s'est beaucoup
occupé d'eux ici s'occupa de la retirer
de l'argent avec également non écoutez
vous est injuste à partir du moment où
elle a eu 13 ans il a retrouvé elle même
et sa mère il les voyait très souvent si
vous avez le journal attentivement vous
en aurez des échos sans arrêt ils
allaient prier avec cali il ya eu il a
parlé beaucoup à sa fille lui a écrit il
essayait de nom mais vous dit avec
ironie
non non pas du tout par exemple il a
essayé de l'empêcher de faire une
carrière artistique parce qu'il trouvait
que dans une carrière artistique c'était
quelque chose d'extrêmement douloureux
qui pouvait conduire à la folie
l'exemple de sa soeur camille on était
une preuve est lui-même sentait qu à peu
de choses près il aurait pu sombrer dans
le même excès et il a donc essayé de
l'empêcher malgré lui elle était quand
même je n'ai jamais prononcé le nom de
sa soeur aînée camille qui est donc
grand grand sculpteur à montner viendra
sculpteur qu'heureux d'un passé à la
sensualité en plus c'est la même somme
sommes tous impatients de voir le le
film d'un week-end septembre/octobre
isabelle adjani joue le rôle de de
camille les deux parties ont re d'un
c'est aussi très part du roda ça va être
un grand événement risque du mato
graphique mais est ce qu'il est vraiment
vous laissez entendre qu'il était jaloux
claudette de la créativité des dons
d'artistes de sa soeur c'est très
complexe
bon c'est vrai qu'il y avait une forme
de jalousie une forme de rivalité mais
après tout c'était aussi pour eux pour
eux deux un aiguillon ils se sont aussi
beaucoup soutenu on ne retient que le
versant négatif de claudel le versant
positif on oublie totalement on le
blitter trouve ça d'une injustice folle
cette soeur camille il a défendu
il l'a recommandé il a loué il parlait
d'elle avec enthousiasme il ya des
articles sur sa soeur camille qu'ils
sont mais remarquable où il parle de son
art où il sent qu'elle était sa force sa
puissance son originalité c'est
extrêmement beau seulement les gens
ignorent c'est alors ils retiennent
camille
asile c'est la faute de claudel et vous
le défendez non je le défends pas il n'a
pas être défendue il n'a pas être
défendue il à être reconnu au sens
claudélien claudel on ne le connaît pas
voyez j'ai pas le défendre j'ai
simplement essayé de montrer ce qu'il a
fait ce qu'il a été bon je vous propose
les des films sur claudel il y en a pas
beaucoup il y en a même pratiquement pas
mais et claudel avait accordé à pierre
dumayet pour lecture pour tous un
entretien à brangues en 1954
voici donc un extrait de lecture pour
tous réalisation jean prat claudel 54 de
l'atmosphère dans laquelle je vis
actuellement le premier que je vous
dirais que c'est un problème que ça fait
de nous de jouer maintenant tout près du
workshop on sait qu'en cas pour l équipe
est considéré comme étampes
circonstances
s'ensuit une relution couleurs très face
aux compagnies esprit de la douleur le
jour nous il avait dit le bon nous
semble et réceptive une odeur le dernier
enseignante s'est tu sur l'écriture les
cinq heures du matin en chantant latin
je reprends l'entraînement il ya la
place donnée c'est lui qui vient de
m'octroyer cette rose byrne au mali la
terre a reçu le baptême bonjour mon beau
soleil
j'essaye raté mobile et où naissent les
3 6 ans de sonel rouge comme un
coquelicot
quand nico quand des pénitents des lacs
à écuires ligne ou le veuf et les rouges
cheval ou naïf et le maréchal comme un
enfant à mes cours le baiser du vent sur
ma joue temps d'être là dit tendez
hyster tant de beauté sur la terre tant
de gloire dans les yeux pleins de larmes
le vieux pour les trusts atua aleida
guerre c'est sur lui tutu cocorico
alléluia vidéo je te pas du plus grand
claudel capirossi permet c'est lui
dirigèrent c'est lui qui avait choisi de
lire ses poèmes
il était très vieux île d'amour vous
avez - quel point les mâles wheels
amassé lors surtout moi ce qui m'a
frappé c'est la manière qui prononce les
amusera les a toujours
mais c'était très important pour lui la
plus belle phrase la plus belle poésie
c'était temps deux royaumes n'ignore pas
ce qu'il y avait une variété des radios
etc
et pour lui la phrase la plus
épouvantable de la langue française
c'était la première de l'oeuvre de
flaubert salambo avec uniquement les
mêmes 1 dans les jardins d'hamilcar
c'était à mes gars à mégara faubourg de
carthage dans les jardins il trouvait
que c'était pour tous les âges mais là
c'est vrai j'ai regardé toutes les
missions l'a donc avait fait qu'on avait
proposé lecture pour tous on voit
vraiment que c'est le patriarche est
vraiment le terrien il a été un moment
de sa vie
c'est vraiment bon mais il y en a eu
bien d'autres il ya eu aussi le délai
novo vous raconter 3
parfois vous avez rencontré claudel et
trois fois c'est une déception
épouvantable oui mais j'appelle ça
images d'époque rien d'autre à c'est pas
une critique de claude hêche papa
comment la ce sens que quand entre
autres quand vous décrivez claudel dans
le train là vous êtes d'une injustice
folle parce que ils recevaient vieux
monsieur rentre dans le travail bon il
ouvre son journal de bourse
il a bien le droit qui l'en empêche je
vous avez l'air de terre mais comment il
a 84 ans il faut il aurait mieux à faire
que dire que vous avez 80 c'est curieux
je crois mais enfin pour réellement
parce que quand j'ai compris que c'était
paul claudel ce monsieur qui a regardé
les cours de la bourse qui a prononcé
ensuite repris hier à mi voix et qui
s'est endormi dans les mains du seigneur
j'ai trouvé ça une attitude dizaines de
pharisien tout simplement contradictoire
non mais je suis peut-être moi très
exigeant mais un homme ou s'ils
respectent et respectable que claudel se
livrer à simple l'histoire de notre nom
mais cette façon de notre-dame raconté à
notre dame en a une messe de noël le du
matin j'étais là avec avec ma femme et
tout à coup il ya un déplacement
incroyable en pleine messe on ouvre une
espèce de barriac était devant la statue
de la vierge du fameux piliers de droite
élu de droite où il a été converti
voilà voilà voilà réduits alors il ya on
avait mis une barricade les gens étaient
très très nombreux il y avait encore
beaucoup de monde à la messe à l'époque
surtout pour nous est et on déplace tout
le monde ya suisse qui arrivent et abdou
je sais pas quoi irons-nous cette
barricade et il y avait un prie dieu et
une chaise et monsieur paul elle
s'installe là j'ai trouvé ça un petit
peu ostentatoire mais 150 à toi mais il
ya aussi il aurait fait part que
n'importe quel autre jour il a aussi
créé la cour d'honneur pareil même merde
mais avant noël pour se faire un passage
du journal qui raconte comment sous la
pluie battante il a fait toutes les
visites académie pour essayer d'être élu
bon c'est merveilleux mais il ya aussi
ça chez claudel je ne nie pas je n'ai
jamais dit que ce n'était pas quelqu'un
qui avait un côté ostentatoire qui il
les aime aussi mais je trouve que c'est
trop facile
injuste et révoltant de juger quelqu'un
sur une apparence mais il n'est qu'à
lire les jeux même je ne juge pas tout
simplement je dis c'est à dire d'avoir
de votre portrait de claudel c'est quand
même or quel hypocrite qu'un parisien
et puis alors vous l'avez rencontré il
est venu dans le lycée vous étiez vous
étiez mais ça ne casse rien
il avait 13 ans il a fait une sorte de
conférence oui et puis vous avez noté
vous vous avez été trouvé ça un peu
minable vous avez dit vous avez mis en
marge
ce commentaire l'ambassadeur est un
paltoquet vous aviez 13 ans oui parce
que j'ai mené dire le chapeau de paille
d'italie
non plutôt le monsieur perrichon me
supérieur donc vous allez comparer à
monsieur perrichon voilà il est vrai qu
donc la chambre d'à côté carrossier le
dernier mot a enregistré fans sur
d'abord ce que c'est ce claudel il est
bien connu
non ce n'est pas bien connu une bonne
vrais grands comptes vous allez voir non
j'étais allé voir le soulier de 7 à la
comédie française les années 45 6 et à
l'entracte claudel croyant leur
connaissions pas nous a abordés
jean-jacques rainieri et moi et nous a
dit alors jeunes gens je ne sais pas
imiter samoa alors jeunes gens que
pensez-vous de du soulier de satin pour
une fois j'ai été très intimidée parce
que l'oeuvre m'avait beaucoup surprise
il ya une chose que j'aurais tout de
même regretter c'est le silence que vous
avez fait sur le mariage sur le mariage
et les conditions n'a pas du tout les
mêmes schémas d'amour vous savez comment
il a connu sa femme mais racontez-moi
savais bien que je sais je ne crois pas
l'avoir trouvée dans votre mur sépare de
leurs annonces écoutez c'est une
biographie qui part de l'oeuvre c'est
vrai il n'ya pas de j'ai donné mon blog
de google
ab non pas jusqu'à présent ça manque non
c'est vrai mais pas seulement mais ça
l'est formidable aussi c'est pas du
famille amis c'est autre chose ce type à
qui a déjà de mortification possible je
ne sais pas quoi
il épouse la femme de l'architecte la
fille de l'architecte plus affreux
monuments de france me parle année les
points à l'envers lui même le diesel a
dit le coureur irlandais en bière vides
par lequel qu'à nous et voir la
république cité de sacré coeur
non
à lyon et il épouse par une marieuse
dont il va trouver non chasseurs
français
oui énormément minable mais ce que
madame guerre se montre bien c'est que
il est quand même choqué par cette
passion qu'il a vécu qu'il a qui la paye
mais alors là les mêmes gars fort sill
très bien que pour claudel c'est qui
fait le mariage ce n'est pas l'amour
mais de consentement mais bon ce qui est
quand même une phrase et il dit aussi
qu'il a épuisé que c'est l'épousé non
les mais oui c'est assez spectaculaire
il voulait fonder une fois il voulait
avoir les oreilles avec l âge déjà à ben
là il avait 37 ans oui c'est mieux pour
se marier ou est un donc il veut fonder
et puis j'en ai assez de la passion
c'est surtout ça ou une vache en 2050 il
est pas tout à fait qu'ils abhorrent il
sait qu'il ne pourra jamais vivre une
passion aussi aussi extrême aussi aussi
riche aussi vivante et que d'autre part
il a absolument besoin de trouver de
donner un sens à sa vie et trouver une
issue à sa sensualité etc
il y avait ici c'est très très patient